[Music]
in wise old coots news wise old wet
coots was that mean like an old person
yeah oh really
let geezer is that what a car yep
submitted by gyrating hips Joey tell
this were you at ladies mines an
industry bar gamer like 12 cents
well that's trash
oh wow you just don't care about the
views of these videos anymore a group of
retired friends rent a booth at a
farmers market each week to give free
life advice Wow I like how old people
think that they're allowed to give
advice I know cuz you could have been a
like loser all your life and it's like
finally people think you're wise like
dude you've been [ __ ] up for 80 years
they've been able to dodge death that
long
that's pretty wise it's like Bill Cosby
dude he's all but you still rapists yeah
he didn't dodge it yep yeah I heard that
bull got a chicken patty slap in his
face and I was I'm so sorry
but [ __ ] I know but it's just like I
wonder how was done like did they take
out the [ __ ] chicken patty or do they
like leave one side on with a bud and
then they went back like that and I
started cracking up I felt sad because I
think of Huxtable Huxtable but I started
cracking up because he's also blind so
he could have never saw it coming so you
fog chilling there eating the jello and
in like that they slapped the [ __ ] up it
happened twice apparently yeah and to me
why why chicken pen lucky was a chicken
patty not a [ __ ] fist oh that's right
damn girl you got some again so did he
come back to you - what do you mean we
should all have something against him
he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] just really blue
Crosby I think it would have been more
satisfying if he was like young and like
right when he did it he got in trouble
for right now it's like your old unit
because he got to reef like he got all
that like benefit in life he got and him
finally it's like he's paying for it now
he had nice cars a nice house nice
pajamas a nice bed Scrabble that's like
if I stole a hundred million dollars
I spent it and had the best [ __ ] life
and now I'm a hundred and it's like
you're going to jail for thieving hmm
it's like all right I already did
everything well okay I just so much
cocaine off [ __ ] all right so these
smelly coke so this group of friends
from Salt Lake City Utah they meet every
Saturday or they used to meet every
Saturday at a friend's Deli they would
have they would drink coffee and just
talk sounds like the episode of The
Sopranos or us in like a few years
that's totally really the story I
totally picked your life it's not gonna
be at a deli it's gonna be at one of our
restaurants it's gonna be at sip it's
one of the friends restaurants yeah oh
yeah so then anyway so then they would I
want a deli now the deli owner and then
it'll be at a [ __ ] deli Joe the deli
owner said he like jokingly said like oh
you know I'm gonna rent a booth across
the street where the farmers market is
every Saturday I'm gonna get us in booth
and we'll give advice and then everyone
thought that he was kidding but then
next thing you know they have a booth
and they set up this banner that says
old coots giving advice it's probably
bad advice but it's free that's oh
that's really cool that's like geezer JK
news cuz we were just talking in a
circle on a park you know let's record
this share six of them - that's cool -
is there a woman in there there is one
woman could probably blame that woman
for all the bad conversations they have
[Laughter]
that's what happens on this channel
yeah the members are the 75 year old
named Lou who's a retired pedia -
pediatrician okay he's a lot - Gus
who's 67 a former elementary school
teacher gets - it's all cash rich 73
years old who used to run a kitchen
countertop business for kids for
preschools John who's 69 a retired Human
Services man
perfect Carol 70 a retired journalist Oh
who's the only female coupe Chris who is
58 a formal local television news
reporter oh and then we got a young and
in there it's an interesting mix little
58 year old yeah
there's Tony who's the deli owner yeah
that's pretty dope that is they all have
the credentials yeah yeah I think um
it's it's really important to have
access to mentors and people that are
older than you that are not your family
members because you have to have access
to different ways of thinking and and
the most important thing is that you
would think that all old people think a
certain way but you know your family
members also live in a bubble what
they're saying like they're saying that
they wanted us it's so cuz it's I mean
they're just talking anyway and they're
saying that it would be nice to have
like a soundboard for other people that
they just there have nothing to gain
from this conversation but they can at
least give them some sort of good advice
so they're saying that the questions
that they get asked it's for example
where can I find someone to love does my
cat why does my cat pee on everything in
the house have I put in enough time at
my new job to take a one-week vacation
people asked like were you guys
qualified to do this they're like of
course some of these sound like there
should be like fortune teller I know
instead of advice it's like what should
my winning lotto numbers be like what
they're mixing it up no there was
another one though where there was this
young girl who she's like really good at
chess and her mom wants her to like quit
school and pursue texts well that's dope
you know they Asia yeah yeah but then
the because it's like her mom because
they play together and if that your
mom's dream to it well she's living
through she's a stage mom yeah so then
the girl was like how do I tell my mom
and like I do love chess but I don't
want to get rid of like all my friends
and like drop school and everything so
like they're gonna giving advice like
that that does kind of sound like a turn
oh now it does huh the ones though that
Tiger parenting comes in feels kind of
asian and live your own life parents
damn why you got to try to live through
your children
I say this now watch when I have kids
[ __ ] that I have this missed opportunity
you're gonna [ __ ] do it mother [ __ ] me
a pirate beat ya you're gonna join the
pirate show and you're gonna be the
captain mother [ __ ]
I wonder what type of parent we would
all be well I know you are a go but you
know what do you think you'll be like
when Tiger gets a little older do you
think you'd be a little more confining I
don't know
coz I know right I grew up that way I
don't know you know I don't think I'm
gonna be confining at all for sure huh
like that you already know cause you're
you have a kid so you already know you
said you already know oh I heard I
already know no I said you already know
but yeah I know what you think about
nothing I don't know about your parent
damn say you don't know what to prepare
you are no cuz you're kidding what if
you make a baby of you like whippin
Isaac's ass that I could sure I could
look at the video and tell you what kind
parent
what about all the videos that I don't
have it but I don't know what kind of it
I just need to see you punch is facing
its off that cute little kid will tell
you that kid forever dude I know you
yeah I'm do it I want him to be taller
and bigger and still climb on I'll be so
cute what kind of berries do you think
you Apple don't fall far from the tree
I'm being absent just kidding
we were watching his Quincy Jones
documentary and you know like he's like
the world's one of the greatest
producers of all time where did you
watch that one on Netflix it's really
[ __ ] amazing but this guy it's like
so you know like a lot of successful
guys in entertainment and poly cos all
kinds of stuff like they can't maintain
like rich guys all that they can't
maintain a marriage and a family and
stuff like that the grain just doesn't
operate that way right and I'm like I'm
like it kind of sucks because it's like
it's always this ultimatum of like
you're either really [ __ ] great in a
legend here but a horrible human being
well not horrible but like you just you
just don't have time for your family you
don't have time for your wife you don't
have time for your kids and then like
you move on and you fall in love with
another person and you have more kids
and then you move on and then file
another person
and you have more kids and it's like it
kind of sucks but then you're known as
this like great person so it's like I
don't know any examples of someone that
maintained a marriage forever and be was
and stayed great Santa Claus oh that's
naughty but he does visit like a million
homes how do you know he doesn't get mad
[ __ ] the way his relationship works
though is he's only working one night
out of the whole damn year so he has so
much time to build yes but he got kids a
lot so he has to check the list and
check it twice like all throughout the
years you know how to delegate his tasks
cuz he has all his [ __ ] yes filets
they'll have to check that he has
disabled slaves she watches you when
you're sleeping I think he's very busy
well I think so huh he's like a
perverted Jesus people yep little people
Oh are they disabled I guess they're
human beings Jess just to let you know
just to put it all I'm saying is he
exploits others that's why and he
doesn't have children I know he doesn't
down I don't know pays them in candy
canes but he pays them but that's no way
to live can you live on candy canes
I can't she'll sit there and eat those
candy canes her [ __ ] teeth fall out
yep
they're almost already but he also
doesn't have kids you see what that mean
though kids yeah okay give me an example
of a powerful rich person male or female
Will Smith nobody has an open
relationship
that's a sec yeah that wasn't confirmed
Oh J does a second yeah yeah it's a
second one yeah you know I had that
older says old I don't was never very
pop someone who's been together yeah
without any cheating without any any
like they've been a unit and then the
success has been going on forever I want
that Denzel Washington I don't know
anything about America know anything
about him either I just know he went to
jail but reasons Oh
what about Bill and melon blade
nevermind he's a nerd he doesn't count
why we don't know like how yeah we don't
know suck Oh anybody might have low
testosterone - yeah he don't look like
he [ __ ] so it's okay you know
I mean think about it like with all that
money
and he's not doing these yacht parties
live in that Dan Bilzerian life
something's wrong with them
that fool likes to jack off the
mousetraps or something like his dick in
him yeah or something cuz I was like
when I was super inspired by Elon Musk I
was reading his Wikipedia and then he
had like five divorces oh [ __ ] Elon Musk
who's a genius on one end but on the
other end it's like [ __ ] it's hard like
always some [ __ ] together I mean you
would just be very boring to talk to
he's weird
yeah he's like his cadence when he
speaks is very odd - yeah it's like a
robot knows what a [ __ ] train is
testicle I'll let you [ __ ] him okay
usually this he'll know what you need to
do is [ __ ] him and then get that come
and pull it out in the [ __ ] thing
like this and save it and freeze that
[ __ ] cuz if you can't get pregnant with
that she got to try again again again
you know what I say which would be more
genius and more lucrative for you guys
all the sperm work thank you baby
damn no jelly just suck my dick know why
I want her to have a baby by them so we
can extort them damn yeah I like that
I'm like an NFL wife you're making way
more money if you saw his sperm by the
truck I don't know I don't want other
people to have his money that's an
ethical right Rob if you sell it by the
drops so you're just like one year right
goodbye I get like chopsticks and take
out one sperm at a time you're gonna be
surprised when you finally just come is
neon green and purple he doesn't have
come alien just you got robotic AI
gasoline or scent likes like some other
it's like it's electric
[Music]
[Music]